you were in australia recently how was
that what was that experience like uh i
love australia i love the people in
australia man i don't like the wildlife
uh
i don't like i don't want to sound sound
angry about it but i am a little bit um
angry about the australian wildlife yes
i am because everything there can kill
you that's why uh we go to this little
petting zoo first of all i didn't have
to go to the petting zoo like we're out
and it's like oh my god kevin hart i
work at the zoo right across the street
you gotta come we'll take you on a
private tour so my girl's like oh we
gotta go i was like well just slow down
what what is the what is the private
tour so she's like well we'll take you
in the back so you can meet all the
animals i was like i don't want to meet
them i don't i don't
i like the glass i like the glass too
yeah yeah so my girl's like babe stop
it'll be fun we go on the back there's
koala bears right true story i'm not
making this up uh first of all they're
like oh they're so lethargic they're
asleep all the time we get in there
they're all up and they're they're just
looking right they're all looking so
instantly instantly i go straight to
racism these are racist koala bears
cause they're asleep all the time
they're nudging each other
i'm like babe and i'm trying to grab my
girl like baby look let's just let's
just stay back we'll need to go all the
way in she's like stop come on she's
like look you can hold them and i'm like
i'm not gonna hold him i said baby you
want to hold it that's on you my girl
goes and she's like standing and there's
a koala bear back here she doesn't see
i'm such a wimp i'm about to take a
picture of her like like standing next
to the koala be here but it's one in the
tree i see the koala bear he's about to
swipe down at her hair i was so scared
that i didn't tell her i wanted i wanted
to record it first
i'm not playing i'm not playing i wanted
it i wanted it for instagram so i'm
looking at her and the koala bear did
this she's like
whoa like he grabbed her hair and the
lady's like oh they just like the smell
of it and she went to like turn and talk
to me i was gone i left i had what i
want i didn't want to be in anymore no
that's ridiculous i didn't want to be in
anymore but every animal we saw was a
violent animal like the kangaroos like i
don't like it when you show me an animal
to tell me what that animal can do if it
gets mad like oh these kangaroos are so
happy but if they get angry they can
kick your chest off what what what do
you mean they can they can kill you for
the kids with their kids yeah the last
trick is to take off your genitals
with their foot because i worked with a
kangaroo once and what do you mean you
worked with a kangaroo what what kid i i
was just had
chuck e cheese at quiznos where were you
working i know you don't like to talk me
to talk about this but i've been on
other tv shows
but no i had to box a kangaroo we had
and they had a real kangaroo
and the trainer said
what in nature what they their main
thing that they try to do to each other
when the males fight is that big nasty
foot is like trying to it's going for
the crotch it's going for you yeah to
try and just like snip
take them right off
did this did kangaroo try to attack you
well first of all i don't need to know
that information because i'm not getting
that close to a kangaroo right second of
all all that they told me they said the
kangaroo used his tail to lean back and
do this and that's all i need to know
like a rocking chair yeah you lost me at
this yeah that's enough for me oh okay
he's dangerous i don't need to know
about the ball part i'm not gonna move
that
i don't even know that's all you needed
so you it's almost like every creature
in australia can kill you everything
like their butterflies will have acid i
guarantee i guarantee in australia
there's something else about that
butterfly yeah guaranteed it's like oh
it's really pretty but unlike other
butterflies this one shoots acid into
your eyeball y'all can think i'm playing
y'all can think i'm playing all you want
everything is dangerous to spiders
there's not regular spiders oh yeah you
guys got to watch out for the for the uh
i think it's the red back or whatever it
is yeah they say it's small you don't
really know it's there but if it bites
you it's over wait what
what
that's how fast they talk that's been
warning you like that's how they warn
you we were in some place and it was a
lot of it was like a lot of dirt and uh
hay in the backyard so i'm out there i'm
just walking and they're like no no
don't go over there we got the brown
snakes they get back there that's the
most poisonous snake in the universe
hold on what what
where is this snake at oh they're
probably back there why are we here